[Music]
Hey
we're about to take the wired
autocomplete cameo it is any poor
Swedish I could see why there could be
no it's Amy Porter dating rashida Jones
yeah clear clean and cuff is Amy poor
related to Louie CK I mean I played his
sister once in its television show and
we do have the same mother well does not
know is Amy Poehler vegan well no I
I respect vegans I get it that you don't
eat something the face for you I think
it's important to make is deep I'm the
jack black character in Tenacious D it's
so funny that no one has known that for
so long you've kept a secret ex parte
hey when is Will Ferrell on SportsCenter
when I do something sports related then
was Will Ferrell on spongebob spongebob
way somebody's impersonate yeah unless
we're assuming that spongebob maybe
spongebob is some other yeah when was
Will Ferrell born I was born uh here we
go
July 16 1980 cancer cancers they're real
in a commenter sideways like perhaps yes
hard-shell
or chill sensitive inside when did Will
Ferrell die he died in a hang gliding
accident as me it's actually falsely
reported really as a
we were shooting blades of glory oh I
love the Internet when did Will Ferrell
learn Spanish in high school and through
college and then employed that knowledge
of Spanish in the major motion picture
Casa de mi padre mmm that was that was
very rich no one see you know you'd like
to do that like every welcome secret
hidden gems what amy poehler doing now
is that question Amy Poehler do
impressed Amy Poehler doing press
what oh dude oh my gosh all the tapes
baby poor go to Boston dollars that's
right
what color are Amy Poehler's eyes tight
we get in tight what sorority was amy
poehler right hand Gamma Phi Beta Pi Phi
Theta Kappa Kappa Gamma nope dg2 have a
cappuccino what is Amy Poehler's dress
cheeky too - too funny - laughs okay
well okay what what will what will
Ferrell characters are you oh I'm
spongebob what is Will Ferrell's email a
sassy pants
that EarthLink dot net dot ie dot super
sexy what is Will Ferrell's pimp name
well I've had the name Gator before what
is Will Ferrell's zodiac sign we already
covered this cancer yep what does Will
Ferrel each in elf spaghetti with maple
syrup M&Ms and maybe some other things
drink volumes of carbonated Cola you
want to hear coke you get up yeah you
got a peg okay we'll say cup right if
you give us something okay okay well
only 17 more we're halfway there how to
Amy Poehler ha
and your answer is that's what happens
when you try to use my voice activated
text and they drive how to pronounce Amy
Poehler thank you for asking actually
older is a German name and the Oh
usually original needs to be Inuit of
course yes German is a pool Lance
landscape architect and their family you
have a very famous pool Landscape
Architect we were the ones that decided
to make it round
how did Amy Poehler and Tina Fey meet
before there was the internet there was
a one-to-one tinder where you would go
into a dark alley it was it was very
analog you have to sign a book and you
get a Polaroid so is the location
specific location you kind of know it
was on a zine was anything how did they
even forget famous good question sir
that was the autocomplete interview I
hope you found it useful
yep in some way just proving once again
the in around this is an amazing
resource and tool so as Amy Poehler
always says stay famous baby